[Music]
so generally I think boy and a lot of
people think that ploy is a awesome
activity it's a it can be a real
exercise it can get you in shape and
tone your body and make your arms strong
and that's good for your brain it's can
be really awesome for your health but
it's physical and like anything you do
physical like any sport there's always
some risk that you will develop an
injury or some repetitive strain
syndrome or something unpleasant this
can usually be avoided with applying a
few things the two most important things
the first one is the warm-up which is
warming the body up loosing the body up
and be able to gently take the body
through ranges of motion to get
everything warm and loose and lubricated
that's super important for avoiding
injury number two is simply good
technique moving the body in healthy
ways versus unhealthy ways so there'll
be something like if you're moving your
arm through big circle having the
movement be part of the whole body and
look at my shoulder it's relaxed and
it's not going into any kind of extreme
position versus doing something like
this right it's still the arm in a big
circle but look I'm I'm putting the arm
through a very uncomfortable position
understanding the difference between a
relaxed full body movement and torquing
on your shoulder it's what's going to
make the difference between making your
shoulder healthier and injuring your
shoulder stretching is also useful but I
think it's like you know it's kind of
like people focus too much on recycling
when reduce and reuse are more important
and also some conditioning some
strengthening and all this together will
make sure that poi is really good for us
and it's not I know hopefully none of us
are developing any problems and that's
my goal and hopefully it's your goal to
and and I'd add to that just listening
to your body actually is another
important one understanding that if you
any kind of sharp pain anything like
that
stop you know if there's you know listen
to pain and of course ask questions
um sometimes you'll ask a question and
all I can say is go see a professional
therapist go see a yoga teacher you need
to find somebody who can see what's
really going on because I'm not a
certified you know health care
practitioner but ask all the questions
you've got and I will keep answering
because I really want this to be really
good for everybody
and that's kind of what we're all doing
together so more on that in the coming
videos
[Music]